one of the most useful realizations we
might come to about ourselves is that we
are paranoid the word is easy to laugh
off as impossibly eccentric evoking
people who insist that they are being
tailed by the Secret Service or watched
over by an alien species but the reality
is a lot more normal looking and far
less comedic feeling to be paranoid in
the true sense is to suffer from a
repeated feeling that most people hate
us that most situations are extremely
dangerous and that some kind of
catastrophe is likely to befall us soon
it may not be immediately obvious what
connects up for example our impression
that a colleague is taking us for a fall
with our fear of being talked about
unkindly by our friends with our
impression that the waiter has
deliberately placed us at the worst
table and our dread that we're about to
be caught up in a scandal
but our sense that the world is
permanently and imminently conspiring to
belittle attack and humiliate us is most
likely the outcome of a very particular
string of experiences of belittlement
attack and humiliation that will have
occurred at the hands of just one or two
people in our formative years and yet
will have been carefully submerged and
overlooked and this will have been done
because we have implicitly preferred to
fear the world rather than acknowledge
the reality of the torment we underwent
at the hands of characters who might
also be our mother or father whom we
would have liked so much to trust and to
love
it's unfortunate that our minds need to
discharge their toxins somewhere and
that if they have been blocked from
doing so in the appropriate location
they will seek to do so anywhere that
feels remotely relevant the office or
the restaurant the party or the
newspaper article the hatred and
viciousness we fear from colleagues
friends or social media is only a proxy
for what we once received from sources
close to home and which we have lacked
the support required to return back to
their senders
understanding who has crushed and
scarred us constitutes a critical part
of adult self-knowledge it is also we
should recognize an Insight we may be
deeply reluctant to secure opting to be
forever terrified rather than raise
arguments against our treatment by
caregivers whom we have chosen to
believe are innocent it may one day feel
as though far fewer people are actually
laughing at us and that there is far
less risk of a scandal soon once we
understand that the mockery and shaming
we anticipate for tomorrow already
unfolded in our heart-rendingly
anguished and unexplored Yesterdays
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life such
as finding a good enough partner and
mastering the art of confidence click
now to learn more